[Musique]
europe ecologie les verts en pleine
reconstruction aussi bien au niveau
national qu'au niveau local et on va en
parler avec david jutier bienvenus vous
recevez politique
vous êtes conseiller municipal
d'opposition à rambouillet conseiller
communautaire mais aussi co responsable
que secrétaire départemental donc
d'europe écologie les verts au niveau
régional pour structurer au niveau
régional départemental aussi mais
principalement au niveau régional à
l'échelle de la france chez les
écologistes alors évoqué une
reconstruction aussi bien au niveau
local qu'au niveau national cette
reconstruction et et or est en marche
vous étiez plutôt partisan d'une union
de la gauche aux dernières législatives
qui n'a pas vu ce qui n'a pas eu lieu
est-ce que l'avenir d'europe écologie
passe par cette union justement de la
gauche
l'avenir d'europe écologie les verts on
est justement en train de le construire
donc je suis bien incapable de vous dire
aujourd'hui par quoi ça passe
l'union de la gauche elle était
nécessaire je pense dans pas mal de
circonscriptions lors des dernières
élections législatives surtout à cause
du mode de scrutin
on a un mode de scrutin pour les
usapistes est particulièrement injuste
qu à un scrutin uninominal à deux tours
et donc la majorité en porte une part et
hégémonique là les prochaines élections
qui vont venir sur les élections
européennes qui sont des élections à un
tour à la proportionnelle qui
conviennent parfaitement aux écologistes
et je pense que dans un avenir proche en
tout cas l'écologie politique passe par
réaffirmer ses fondements cesser ses
positions et son et son autonomie le
fondement d'europe écologie c'est quoi
justement le fondement d'écologie de
l'écologie en france aujourd'hui c'est
de proposer un projet post croissance un
projet alternatif à cette terre ces
terres qui étaient jusqu'à présent
fondée uniquement sur la recherche de la
croissance de l'augmentation du pib
cette idée que si on augmente la le
développement économique ça va profiter
un maximum de personnes la fameuse
théorie du ruissellement des manuels
macron dont on voit quelle qu'elles ne
fonctionnent pas et donc
vraiment le socle programmatique
d'europe écologie les verts
actuellement il est là avec un volet
évidemment très environnementale
l'écologiste un volet social à volet
économique est envolé démocratique ça me
paraît aussi tout à fait indispensable
et donc on est en train d'y travailler
on a ouvert une grande période de
réflexion on appelle les assises de
l'écologie demain l'écologie de nombreux
événements sont en cours d'organisation
en france on convie tous nos partenaires
les associations les autres partis
politiques qui partagent un certain
nombre de valeurs avec nous et puis à
partir de septembre
on va rentrer dans un processus de
fondation d'un mouvement rénové d'un
nouveau mouvement de l'écologie
politique
aujourd'hui je suis bien incapable de
vous dire comment il s'appellera comment
il sera gouverné en tout cas on prépare
la séquence suivante celle qui s'achève
avait été initié en 2009 2010 avec la
création d'europe écologie les verts qui
avaient été un formidable mouvement
d'expansion de l'écologie politique
aussi bien dans les consciences que dans
les urnes réalisé de très beaux scores à
cette période là et puis pour un certain
nombre de raisons on s'est un peu
abîmées on s'est perdus et donc
aujourd'hui l'idée c'est de se retrouver
et de fonder un nouveau mouvement de
l'écologie politique pour porter ce
projet qui qui est le seul à pouvoir
dans l'avenir porter un
une société qui à la fois à sur
l'épanouissement des individus protège
notre notre environnement notre planète
et puis qui permettent de rénover la
démocratie qu est complètement sclérosée
aujourd'hui emmanuel emmanuel macron et
son gouvernement et sa manière de faire
est l'archétype de la sclérose et de la
vieille manière de faire de la politique
en france dont il faut absolument
tourner la page
à quel moment vous avez décidé de
rejoindre les écologistes alors moi j'ai
las d'errer un parti politique pour la
première fois avec europe ecologie les
verts j'aurais jamais eu l'idée
d'adhérer ailleurs moi je viens de
l'écologie scientifique
j'ai fait des études de
de biologie puis en biodiversité
écologie et génétique
donc c'est l'écologie scientifique on va
dire qu'il m'a dit m'a amené ensuite à
passer le pas de l'engagement de
l'engagement politique je faisais un
peut pas juste se contenter d'avoir une
approche rationnelle scientifique étudié
étudier les choses et puis les voir se
dégrader le le constater bah oui
clairement les chiffres nous disent que
et puis quand ce genre de choses il
fallait cet engagement polyphosphates
l'élément déclencheur ça s'est fait à
quel moment l'élément déclencheur je
pense que ça a été l'élection de nicolas
sarkozy à la présidentielle
et quand j'ai vu les politiques
osterrieth r absolument terrible qui le
mettait en place aussi bien pour les
gens que pour la nature que pour que
pour la démocratie est à ce moment là
j'avais aussi une opportunité
professionnelle à ce moment là je venais
de quitter un métier extrêmement
extrêmement prenant j'étais en
reconversion
c'était le moment de se reposer aussi
des questions sur sur sa place dans la
cité sur sur ce qu'on veut porter donc
j'ai choisi à ce moment-là de rejoindre
europe écologie les verts en 2011
et ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui la
politique occupe la plus grande partie
de votre temps la notion de parenthèses
la vie professionnelle
non pas du tout puisque vous l'avez dit
je suis élue d'opposition à rambouillet
donc j'ai pas d'indemnités donc le
travail qui est fait à rambouillet et
dans l'agglomération et est purement
bénévole comme celui de marianne plo de
beaulieu qui est élu avec moi on ménage
pas notre note peine mais pour autant on
a on a un travail à temps plein et
j'essaye d'organiser tout ça c'est pas
c'est pas tous les jours facile je vous
le concède les week-ends sont bien
chargées le week-end dernier j'ai passé
encore le samedi
à manifester à paris pour la grande
marche populaire qui était organisée à
l'appel d'attac du collectif copernic le
dimanche j'étais en soutien au collectif
non au projet europa city sur le
triangle de gonesse
et voilà on est sur le terrain on est là
et puis localement à rambouillet je suis
évidemment aller coûte à l'écouté de la
population et on travaille mais non il
faut concilier vie personnelle vie
professionnelle et engagement politique
vous vous souvenez de votre premier
combat en politique sur le terrain vous
parler de ces manifestations sur le
terrain vous vous souvenez notre
première mobilisation
ma première grande mobilisation c'était
c'était à paris contre le contre le smic
jeunes c'étaient les premières grandes
mobilisations alors ça doit être ça
devait être edouard balladur a à ce
moment là donc j'étais j'étais lycéen
effectivement ça va ça va énormément
marqué ces millions de personnes dans la
rue je pense qu'effectivement il ya eu à
ce moment là aussi
un déclic quelque chose qui a commencé à
se mettre à se mettre en place 60
chaque chaque personne qui est engagée
chez les écologistes comme d'ailleurs
dans toutes les formations politiques a
eu je pense à un moment donné un
événement fondateur ou alors un parcours
familial aussi on a beaucoup de
personnes qui se transmettent des
valeurs parce que parce que les parents
s'est engagée parce que cousin parce que
et ça a été le cas chez vous non pas du
tout mais alors pas du tout il n'y a pas
de réglage formation n'aime pas
d'engagement public par les douanes
forcément beaucoup poli dans la famille
on parlait pas plus politique que dans
la majorité des familles je pense non
pas du pas du tout mon engagement chez
les écologistes il vient vraiment de mon
parcours universitaire et de ma
formation scientifique vous arrivez à
les convertir ma grande joie à ma grande
joie effectivement mais mes parents
récemment la retraite ont décidé de
s'investir de créer une association et
je pense qu'effectivement
le fait de me voir moi autant engager
les a sans doute poussé à se poser des
questions et réagir quand ils en ont eu
le temps et l'opportunité vous êtes
engagé vous l'avez dit militant et puis
vous avez été candidat de nombreux
scrutins aussi est ce que c'est le cas
pour 2019 pour les européennes est
peut-être après aussi pour les
européennes
vous l'avez rappelé en introduction je
suis le co secrétaire régional d'europe
écologie les verts ile-de-france et donc
à ce titre là j'aurai à soutenir la
campagne des européennes qui va ce qui
va se lancer on va avoir une équipe de
campagne par une liste on va avoir un
programme donc si si jamais on me
sollicite pour porter les choses dans
les yvelines je serai candidat sur une
place qui sera pas éligible ça c'est ça
c'est certain
moi je privilégie pour l'instant mon
engagement local je me suis présentée
devant les électeurs et les électrices
en 2014 pour porter un mandat un double
mandat puisque je suis aussi élevé à
l'agglomération et je me ferai jusqu'au
bout et uniquement sur ceux sur ce
mandat là ça c'est certain
après sur les élections suivantes qui
sont les municipales on commence à y ont
commencé à y réfléchir on commence à y
travailler là il y a
gros il ya un gros travail à faire
effectivement parce qu on est dans une
terre le sud yvelines qui est magnifique
et à laquelle moi je me suis beaucoup
attaché depuis que je suis arrivé il ya
un peu plus d'une dizaine d'années et
qui est gérée de manière extrêmement
traditionalistes conservatrice voire
parfois réactionnaire alors qu' il ya
des gens formidables
il ya un niveau de diplôme moyen par
habitant qui est extrêmement élevé et de
l'autre côté on a aussi des populations
qui sont beaucoup plus défavorisés donc
il ya une fracture importante à réduire
et puis on a un potentiel pour
développer des programmes écologistes et
mettre en place des projets des
structures qui montre que l'écologie
lorsque les écologistes sont au pouvoir
ça marche qui est extrêmement important
bon j'en reviens là la recomposition de
la gauche pour pour l'avenir justement
parce que vous parliez de ses prochains
scrutins il ya toute une recomposition
en cours du côté de l'europe écologie et
de la gauche les choses évoluent au
niveau de la région par exemple
mounir cet ouvrier europe écologie a été
rejoint par benoît hamon absolument
notamment absolument les deux les deux
groupes ont souhaité faire un groupe
unique et le groupe de benoît hamon
s'est fondu dans le groupe
le groupe écologiste 7
une manière aussi d'être plus audi plus
visible d'avoir plus de moyens à la
région c'est un accord qui est pas
uniquement technique évidemment
puisqu'on partagent de nombreuses
valeurs avec avec le mouvement de benoît
hamon
mais c'était c'est pas quelque chose qui
préfigure une configuration nationale
absolument pas c'est pas quelque chose
que vous souhaiteriez en tout cas vous
personnellement peut-être alors moi
personnellement ce que je souhaite c'est
que un mouvement fort de l'écologie
politique autonome persiste en france et
c'est le chemin c'est la direction que
comprend comprend actuellement notamment
pour les pour les européennes c'est là
c'est la plus probable on va dire en
tout cas c'est celle que moi je
soutiendrai à titre personnel ensuite
effectivement l'écologie politique à la
vocation à travailler avec toutes les
toutes les composantes qui partagent des
valeurs avec benoît hamon on a une
partie du programme très forte en commun
il a repris des thématiques qui nous
sont chères depuis très longtemps la
6ème république
le revenu le revenu de base universel
par exemple la la la la transition
écologistes évidemment tout ça sont des
thèmes qui sont portées depuis très
longtemps par les écologistes que benoît
hamon a repris formidable dans ce cas-là
discutons parlons ensemble construisons
sur le sur le terrain ça veut pas dire
qu'on va faire une seule grande maison
avec pour terminer un questionnaire
rapide votre livre de chevet
actuellement je viens juste de relire de
terminer un ouvrage qui s'appelle mes
années grizzlies de peacock qui est un
auteur américain et qui racontent qu'ils
racontent ses pérégrinations en terre
russe lit dans l'est dans les rocheuses
avec avec une à une réflexion
écologistes
très profonde et ça ça fait du bien de
relire les fondamentaux de temps en
temps dernier film au cinéma au cinéma à
ça fait tellement longtemps que j'ai pas
eu l'occasion d'aller au cinéma
j'avais le temps c'est vrai c'est assez
dommage je pense que j'ai dû accompagner
les enfants voir un film d'animation il
ya
il ya plusieurs mois mais je suis
incapable de vous dire quels films que
j'ai vus au cinéma et artiste musical
qui en ce moment
vous trotte dans la tête une chanson qui
vous trotte dans la tête en ce moment
j'aurais écoute beaucoup de jeunes buzz
voilà je suis
fans des artistes des années 60-70 aussi
bien du rock de ces années là que john
baez qui est plutôt sur le registre folk
mais quelqu'un de formidable très engagé
une féministe de la première heure donc
c'est quelque chose que j'aime beaucoup
merci beaucoup david itié d'avoir
participé au bal merci rebouc
[Musique]
oui